How do we thrive in a world where every
which way we turn our fear is being
activated by politicians,
by the media,
and by the desperate events that are
happening around us.
What is really fascinating when we look
at the brain research around fear is
that our brains proxy anything that
feels unfamiliar,
incoherent or inaccessible as being
unsafe.
So let me give you an example.
There is fascinating research that shows
that when people have lower levels of
self esteem and they are in a job in
which they are recognized and promoted,
that promotion can feel incoherent to
the person with low self esteem.
They have low self esteem and they might
be used to and expecting to be treated
badly.
So what is fascinating is the results
showing that when people are promoted,
when they have lower levels of self
esteem,
they are more likely to leave their
jobs.
Fear is an incredibly,
incredibly powerful force in our lives
and our brains have fairly immature in
assessing anything that feels slightly
incoherent or unfamiliar as unsafe.
What this might mean is that if you are
used to hearing a story time and time
again from a parent or from a partner
about how you are not good enough,
you are more likely to be drawn to that
relationship because it feels familiar.
The messaging that you are getting time
and time again is connected with what
you expect to get when we have
politicians who are effectively
demagogues,
who are inspiring fear in us,
that fear leads to very particular and
relatively predictable responses.
When we are fearful,
there is this idea in psychological
research of mortality salience that when
our mortality is threatened,
when someone says,
Oh,
this group of people is out to get you
and we feel that we are actively being
threatened,
we are more likely to stereotype.
We are more likely as individuals to
become bigoted.
We are more likely to respond to
messages that we hear time and time
again,
even if they are against our values as
somehow making sense to us.
How do we protect ourselves against
this?
Daniel Conaman describes system one
thinking and system two thinking system.
One thinking is the intuitive response,
the emotional,
visceral us and them that can sometimes
arise out of fear system.
Two is the deliberate thoughtful
examination of what is this person
saying?
Is it aligned with how I really want to
be?
Is it connected with how I really wanted
to raise my children?
Is this a world that I wanted to
support?
When we are able to step back from our
fear,
not to pretend that it doesn't exist,
but to see our fear for what it is fear
not a direction,
but data and an emotion.
When we are able to step back from the
fear and able to assess the fear and
assist the messaging from the place of
our values in a more deliberate,
thoughtful way,
we are able to come to a place where we
are ultimately protect it from the
demagoguery message,
from the message of fear and are able to
move ourselves forward in a way that is
aligned with how we truly want to be and
with a world that we truly want to live
in.
When Donald Trump first started with all
of this messaging,
we used to hear things that the
politicians would say and we would be
like,
oh my goodness,
how can the person possibly say that
thing?
But what happens over time is the more
familiar something sounds so the more
we've heard it,
time and time again,
even if the story is inaccurate,
even if the story doesn't serve us,
the more we're likely to become inured
to it and immune to it.
So what I actually think from a media
perspective is when I speak to people in
the media about this,
they will often say,
well,
we simply go with the story takes us.
So we'll give as much coverage to
wherever the stories at even if the
story is one that incites hatred or
violence.
But I actually think that there is a
very,
very powerful ethical choice that the
media makes a net.
Because when they expose and expose and
expose and expose a story that is about
hatred and a story that is about
violence as human beings,
the more familiar we become with that
story,
the more insured we become to it.
And I think we can see exactly this in
the current elections,
that things that were said six months
ago where everyone was horrified that a
politician could possibly even prevail
on people to listen to what was being
said or not being met with,
oh,
there we go again.
We somehow have become inured to the
messaging because of the familiarity
with which we are hearing it and I think
it's really important for us as a
society and for us as voters to
recognize that a familiar story is not
necessarily a truthful story.
A familiar story might sound comfortable
and our brains might proxy that story
for meaning safe and therefore right and
therefore comfortable.
But that story doesn't necessarily
reflect us or what we value.
And it's really important to be able to
step out from the safety of what might
at this point feel familiar and really
recognize the words for what they are.
They are words that are inciting hatred
and division and stereotyping in us as a
society.
And for many of us,
that's not the society in which we want
to live.
And I think there's a moral impetus on
us to be able to step back from the
story and step forward with our values.